[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition de votre journal local
voici les titres de ce mercredi est 5
juillet beaucoup de sourires et quelques
larmes les résultats du baccalauréat a
été dévoilée ce matin nous étions à
versailles pour suivre des étudiants et
leurs parents dans ce moment crucial
éviter les fausses nouvelles et
décrypter les informations la préfecture
des yvelines organisé un séminaire
autour de l'éducation aux médias pour
les quartiers prioritaires de la
politique de la ville éducateurs élus et
journalistes ont échangé le temps d'une
après midi
l'occasion aussi de renforcer le lien
entre médias et quartier acteur majeur
en france de la lutte contre la
transmission de nombreuses maladies
l'association hf prévention vient
d'inaugurer ses nouveaux locaux attrape
une étape de plus qui marque aussi un
élargissement du champ d'action de
l'association
l'hommage était forcément nationale ce
mercredi pour saluer l la mémoire de
simone veil la femme politique est
rescapé de la shoah reposera avec son
époux au panthéon celle annonces du
président de la république ce matin lors
de son éloge funèbre
celles qui restent avant tout dans
l'esprit des français pour avoir
légalisé l'avortement en 1975 en tant
que ministre a donné aussi son nom à la
faculté de médecine de saint quentin en
yvelines
elle était d'ailleurs présente vous le
voyez lors de l'inauguration le 3
décembre 2012
et aujourd'hui nous sommes allés dans
les rues de l'agglomération recueillir
vos témoignages au micro de patrick
jacques de dixmude eu une belle femme
entre guillemets sur tous les plans qui
a apporté beaucoup beaucoup de choses à
nous les femmes déjà serré qu'à aider
les fameux pour la vente mon sens
inverse on n'aurait pas cru
[Musique]
donc voilà c'est un bon souvenir elle
nous a donné un bouquet deux femmes il
femme en tant que femme est une femme
politique extraordinaire comme on en
fait comme il y en a plus aujourd'hui
quoi honnêtes intègres profondément
humaine une femme de caractère qui
prenaient les choses en voit le corps
une vrai visionnaire est quelqu'un de
très courageux
voilà était fidèle à ses convictions qui
a su s'imposer dans d une situation
difficile j'ai une grande admiration
pour elle l'actualité de ce mercredi est
marquée aussi par les résultats du
baccalauréat
c'est la fin du suspense pour les
étudiants comme le lycée marie curie à
versailles les petites listes qui
délivre le précieux sésame ont provoqué
et là-bas explosion de joie mais aussi
malheureusement quelques larmes
un sujet de charline hurel
10h ce matin les portes du lycée
marie-curie souvent les lycées en se
précipitent à l'intérieur du bâtiment
une dernière épreuve les attend avant le
soulagement trouvé leur nom dans ses
longues listes pour savoir si vous ont
obtenu leur baccalauréat en quelques
minutes sur l'anxiété et le stress
dissipe et laisse place aux cris de joie
et fusion et larmes
[Musique]
c'est quoi ta meilleure note
j'ai eu à
j'étais pas sûr
maintenant c'est vrai
[Musique]
benoît y est sympathique ça fait
toujours vraiment le joueur même si
l'élève
l'année n'a toujours pas ce moteur
à peine remis de leurs émotions les
bacheliers vont chercher leurs dossiers
dans les files d'attentes les lycéens
trépigne d'impatience après une
signature
ils peuvent enfin découvrir les notes
qu'ils ont obtenu lire s'envole dans la
salle les feuilles de nox s'échangent
entre amis pas peu fier
m
tout en moi
[Musique]
ce
une fierté partagée par les professeurs
résultat à la main les diplômés se
précipite vers ceux qui les ont
accompagnés toute l'année pour leur
annoncer la bonne nouvelle
on se rappellera qu'à aussi c'était pas
si loin
forcément
la prise de notes c'est pour le
du côté statistique voir si c'est à peu
près cohérent extrait nous maintenir
l'an dernier les départements avaient
obtenu 88,8 % de réussite au
baccalauréat un résultat au dessus de la
moyenne nationale mais il faudra
attendre vendredi et la fin des épreuves
de rattrapage pour savoir si les
yvelines enregistre cette année encore
un bon résultat
et puis bien sûr on souhaite bonne
chance à ceux qui sont justement au
rattrapage l'éducation décidément au
coeur de l'actualité aujourd'hui les
parents d'élèves et les professeurs des
collèges protesté cet après midi à
guyancourt contre les ajustements de
dotation mise en place par la direction
des services départementaux de
l'éducation nationale une dotation qui
touche les établissements des yvelines
et qui nuit selon alors bon
fonctionnement les précisions avec ce
reportage d'haussmann vendeurs d à
l'appel du syndicat snes 78 ils sont une
vingtaine devant les locaux de la
direction des services départementaux de
l'éducation nationale
parmi eux des professeurs et des parents
d'élèves qui protestent contre les
ajustements de dotation dans les
établissements des yvelines
aujourd'hui on se rassemble dans le
cadre des ajustements de dotation
horaire c'est à dire c'est le nombre
d'heures d'enseignement qui sont
attribués à chaque établissement pour
protester contre des ajustements qui ont
été faits par la direction académique
des yvelines et qui conduisent en fait à
tout simplement reprendre des moyens
certains établissements pour les
attribuer à d'autres
alors que les projets les dispositifs
dead sont mis en place et qui sont remis
en cause par ces ajustements selon le
syndicat les conséquences sont lourdes
pour les établissements comme des
projets qui ne peuvent plus être financé
des dispositifs dead qui disparaissent
ont encore des postes fragilisé à cause
du sureffectif des classes à la rentrée
prochaine certaines classes de 6e pour
être composée de 32 élèves
oui les élèves en pâtissent ne serait ce
que parce que pour pouvoir les
accueillir sereinement en septembre il
faut avoir préparé le travail en amont
et que s'ils travaillent qui a été
préparé et des faits au mois de juillet
évidemment nous inquiète pas dans
d'aussi bonnes conditions si vous avez
prévu de suivre une classe de 5e avec
des petits groupes tout au long de
l'année qu'on vous annonce qu'en fait
vous allez être deux professeurs sur une
même classe sans dédoublement ce ne sont
pas du tout les mêmes conditions
d'accueil l'inspection académique n'a
pas souhaité s'exprimer sur le sujet
le snes 78 espèrent être reçus dans les
prochaines semaines par les services
départementaux de l'éducation nationale
engager le dialogue entre journalistes
et acteurs des quartiers prioritaires
c'était l'objectif d'un séminaire
organisé hier par la préfecture des
yvelines
des journalistes de france télévisions
ont animé une après midi d'échangés à
laquelle ont participé
250 personnes les détails avec camille
lambert fabriquer un journal éviter
l'effet que muse et mener une enquête
voilà les thématiques abordées tout
l'après-midi un séminaire pour favoriser
le dialogue entre acteurs de
l'information et habitants des quartiers
prioritaires
chaque mot vous dites besoin est
important le lien était dégradée parce
que ça ne valorise pas les habitants que
de toujours voir au journal télévision
télévisée des barres d'immeubles des
voitures qui brûlent des poubelles qui
brûlent des violences urbaines
donc il fallait vraiment que les
habitants des quartiers les
professionnels soit face aux
journalistes et qu'ils se parent doit
être conscients qu'ils sont porteurs
d'un message qui peut dévastateur ou
très bénéfique
et si on ne fait pas attention mais on
peut catapulter une commune par exemple
quand la mienne quinze ans en arrière
retrouver une confiance mutuelle par un
échange sincère de 150 élus policiers
éducateurs et travailleurs sociaux ont
participé à cette conférence animée par
des journalistes de france télévisions
pour le rédacteur en chef du magazine
enquêtes de france deux caches
investigations plus d'événements de ce
type devraient avoir lieu
et une très grande défiance vis-à-vis du
travail des journalistes et vis-à-vis de
l'information en général je crois que
voilà le seul moyen de sortir cette
défiance et devenir de s'expliquer
l'éducation à l'image l'éducation alain
faute doit faire partie de ce qu'on
apprend de ce qu'on apprend dans l'est
dans les écoles c'est important parce
que ça fait partie de la vie ce
partenariat entre france télévisions et
la préfecture des yvelines a été mis en
place en début d'année 2010 est il a
permis de réaliser différentes actions
d'éducation aux médias direction glee
est en cours à présent où la nouvelle
clinique du pont du routard a été
officiellement inaugurée hier ouverte
depuis le 11 janvier et déjà ce nouvel
établissement médical participe à la
restructuration générale du quartier
la maire de la ville marie christine le
tarnac étaient présentes pour l'occasion
présentation de ce projet privé estimée
à 16 millions d'euros par miquel et demi
d'euros et mathilde ans qu'hier
mesdames messieurs bienvenue à vous tous
dans ce nouvel établissement de korian
guyancourt une soixantaine de personnes
était réunie ce mardi 4 juillet pour
l'inauguration officielle de la nouvelle
clinique privée korian le grand parc
cet établissement de 6000 mètres carrés
situé dans le quartier du pont du
routard pour accueillir une centaine de
patients pour une durée moyenne d'une
trentaine de jours ici on traite des
patients qui ont subi une intervention
chirurgicale et on les réhabilite pour
qu'ils puissent reprendre leur vie
normale
donc nous sommes la suite logique de la
médecine interventionnelle donc vous
avez dans le secteur interventionnelle
une opération et les gens derrière ont
besoin d'un certain nombre de pratiques
de rééducation qui sont donnés ici et
qui leur permettent de retrouver une vie
tout à fait normale dans cette troisième
cliniques du groupe implantée dans les
yvelines les patients sont pris en main
par plus de 124 salariés dont 80 sont
spécialisées dans les soins les méthodes
qui a séduit la mairie il ya quatre ans
avec 10% de sa population âgée de plus
de 60 ans la ville espère avec cet
établissement répondre au mieux aux
attentes des seniors de la commune à
guyancourt on essaye d'avoir une offre
de soins là la plus importante pour les
u en cours
on à la maison de pury disciplinaire de
santé qui va ouvrir ses portes au mois
de septembre un projet effectivement un
partenariat avec les médecins du secteur
et puis cette clinique de soins qui va
compléter sa sera très intéressant pour
l'ensemble du lion courtois qui ont déjà
commencé à investir cette clinique dans
le cadre de suite de soins coût total
des travaux 16 millions d'euros
entièrement prise en charge par des
financements privés
une autre inauguration dans l'actualité
locale mais à trappes cette fois ci
l'association hf prévention a présenté à
ses différents partenaires ses nouveaux
locaux 130 m² flambant neuf qui marque
un tournant dans les actions que mène l
association depuis une dizaine d'années
d'année pour la prévention d'un grand
nombre de maladies les détails avec ses
images de charline hurel plus grand et
plus pratique
hf prévention franchi une nouvelle étape
avec ses locaux si tu attrapes
l'association spécialisée initialement
dans la prévention du sida et les
infections sexuellement transmissibles
poursuit aussi le développement de ses
activités
l'idée c'était d'avoir un siège national
pour hf prévention alors nous sommes
toujours à l'institut de promotion de la
santé pour l'ile-de-france ouest mais
effectivement le ciel nationale
multiplie ses actions des nouveaux
concepts le cardiaque cardiovasculaires
donc tout ce qui va être aussi associée
à la nutrition
le diabète toujours la santé sexuelle et
c'est vrai que pour le coup il y avait
une vraie nécessité d'avoir un siège
national qui puisse effectivement se
développer et développer les actions
partout en france présente sur le
terrain depuis plus de 10 ans auprès des
populations à risque dans les quartiers
différents lieux de vie hf prévention
est devenu un acteur incontournable de
la lutte contre la transmission des
maladies chroniques et des affections de
longue durée
l'association est également connu pour
ses innovations comme l'application tube
trouver un préservatif une première en
france lancée en 2014
elle est aussi à respecter pour son
travail avec les différents acteurs de
la santé
la particularité d'hachette prévention
ceux qui vont sur le terrain
ils vont dans les lieux de drague
extérieur et à l'heure actuelle
il ya plus grand monde qui va dans ces
lieux là parce qu'il faut y aller il
faut il faut connaître les lieux il faut
il passer du temps il faut aller à la
rencontre des gens et c'est pas très
facile pour poursuivre ses actions
locales dans l'ouest parisien hf
prévention conserve ses locaux situés à
l'institut de promotion de la santé de
saint quentin en yvelines
c'est la fin de ce journal tous nos
reportages sont pas à retrouver sur
notre site internet et l'application tv
soixante dix huit bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]